[Music]
[Applause]
football morning in America must read
Peter King joining us he went to the
Giants Eagles Cowboys Niners divisional
playoff games he'll be covering the AFC
title game of the Bengals and Chiefs
coming up on Sunday before we talk
football here Pete Scott Roland Hall of
Famer what do you think well I didn't
know my gut feeling was I thought that
was a reach but I texted Pete Abraham my
buddy who works for the Boston Globe and
who knows a lot more about this than I
did and
he told me that in his time that the
only guys who had better War than him I
think he said A-Rod
bonds and Chipper Jones in his career
and the other thing is he won eight gold
gloves
and he won a gold glove at age 35. so
look I have the same questions probably
a lot of people do but I don't I don't
know it well enough to have a strong
opinion but I really do like defense and
so and I know Scott Roland is PR
certainly one of the five best defensive
third baseman of all time so I don't
know I I don't have a problem with it
yeah it just baseball has lost star
power you have Ichiro uh Aaron judge
star power and you know somebody like
Scott Roland is a really good player but
there's no star power like Dale Murphy
star power Don Mattingly star power but
they're not going to get into the Hall
of Fame yeah I don't know I I have a
hard enough time with the Football Hall
of Fame I'll be honest with you it is
just wearysome yeah it's like it never
ends the discussion never ends I
guarantee you when the class is
announced this year I'm gonna get 900 uh
tweets or emails or whatever's saying
you incompetent boobs why couldn't you
put John Doe in you know so I don't know
well it's what's the most what's the
most heated it's gotten over a player
going in or not going into the Pro
Football Hall of Fame
I would say uh uh over the years I can
go way way back uh I mean it was fairly
heated about like for instance Lynn
Swann you know because he only had 336
catches
uh and you know it gets heated about
certain guys it was a little bit heated
about Sam Mills in the last couple of
years there's some people who really
don't think he he was uh you know he he
did enough I fervently disagreed
but you know Dan it's I I can't think of
one I do Paul taglia boo was really a a
candidate who divided the room over the
years and you know he finally got in
with the Centennial committee uh so look
I don't know there's a lot of times when
when I leave that meeting and I feel
fantastic because I love the class and
there's a lot of times where I leave the
meeting shaking my head but you know
what I'm on a 49 so my vote shouldn't
count and certainly doesn't count more
than anybody else
Roger Goodell growing the game I mean do
we look at a commissioner and say did he
grow the game or
like what what would be the ball I'm
guessing a Hall of Famer
does that sound right I would assume
that one day he'd probably make the Hall
of Fame anybody who's been a
commissioner for a long time has made
the Hall of Fame okay and you know right
now as we sit here let's see it was uh
September 1 2006 so as of this year
it'll be 17 years
and that's that is the tenure of Paul
taglia boost 17 years and I don't think
Roger has any designs of leaving soon
um I would assume he'd make it one day
I'm glad I probably won't be sitting in
Judgment at that time but uh you know
we'll see
talking to Peter King football morning
in America columnist uh you had uh some
details about Aaron Rodgers in your
column what's the market what would the
market be for Aaron Rodgers all I said
in that column I mean you know it's
amazing what's going on in the Twitter
sphere in the last 36 hours
I never said that the Packers wanted two
ones I never said that the Jets
definitely are going after them I don't
know what's going to happen I'm sitting
in my uh I'm actually sitting on a plane
flying from Philly to San Jose doing a
bunch of things and that's one of the
things I'm doing and I just tried to uh
sort of put my thinking cap on and I
said after listening to Adam schefter on
Saturday what really is the market for
Aaron Rodgers and what would happen just
a guess that's all this is a guess this
is nobody on the Packers telling me
anything
and I didn't pass it off as that but my
guess is that they'd probably want two
ones would they get it I don't know uh
would there be a team out there as
desperate as say the Jets might be after
listening to Woody Johnson after the
season
I don't know we'll see but I do think
the Jets make sense from the standpoint
that Woody Johnson looks at his team and
says we have not had a franchise
quarterback seriously
in the last half century we haven't had
a franchise quarterback since Joe Namath
and you know I'm tired of it and I don't
care what it costs and Dan the best
thing about getting Aaron Rodgers is
that whatever team he has you know he's
gonna Aaron Rodgers is going to cost
48.5 million dollars on the cap combined
over the next two years so you know it's
not going to your team Dak
Prescott's cap number next year
is higher than Aaron Rodgers cap number
for the next two years combined wow
yeah I'm just wondering what Green Bay
wants to do in this situation that does
does Rogers have the leverage here and
if you're Green Bay you sort of have to
acquiesce to whatever his I think I
think Mike Florio made this point and I
think he's absolutely right listen if
Aaron Rodgers doesn't want to go he can
either say one of two things
I'm not going to report to team X
uh so you can either pay me all this
guaranteed money or let me continue
playing quarterback for the Packers or
let me pick the team that I want to go
to
but again I think we're so early in the
process Rogers said it I guess to Pat
McAfee that you know he's just been
vegging out and good for him he should
take some time there's no there's there
is no rush because really the way this
contract is written he almost has to be
traded after June 1 for cap reasons so
you know I don't think anybody should be
in any hurry about this Tom Brady's
response to Jim Gray when Jim was saying
hey kind of give you got a time frame
here it almost felt like it was fake
anger to kind of throw us off the scent
that there's no way Tom would be
tampering with a team or vice versa
right now my am I reading too much into
he's best friends with Jim Gray you
would have thought that it was you know
some schlub who was asking him in a
press conference I don't know Dan I felt
like it was
you know I think Tom probably felt I
don't I can't remember this but Jim Gray
probably asked him a similar question
last week and now I but again I don't
know I shouldn't even say that I I would
assume he did in his first post-season
thing when are you gonna decide whatever
uh so I I would I thought it was
legitimate snippiness but maybe it
wasn't and look I just I think that
Brady I think honestly deep down I think
Brady probably wants to play
um but I think he probably wants to go
to a place that truly does want him and
that he thinks he has a legitimate
chance for all these people who say well
he wouldn't go there because they don't
have a chance let's let's just remember
oh he wouldn't go to Vegas why
I mean why wouldn't he go to Vegas and I
understand you're in a division with two
all-world quarterbacks I get that but
but he went to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
who were seven and nine and I even
though look I don't know many people
have predicted him to do great things in
2020 I did but that's because I didn't
think this team was as bad as it showed
when Jameis Winston threw 33
interceptions in 2019 so I I don't I
don't have a gut feeling either way I or
I should say I have a gut feeling of
play but that's just an absolute gut
feeling it's with no knowledge
whatsoever but Pete It's tricky because
we go well he can't go out this way
there's no guarantee that next year will
be any better than this year and then
then what do you do listen hey Dan how
about how about uh and you know all that
stuff it doesn't matter
it just simply doesn't matter you know
how I can tell you why it doesn't matter
I was in Denver Broncos training camp
when a 43 maybe 40 whatever he was 42 43
year old Jerry Rice
was getting shut down by a free agent
rookie from Bowling Green in training
camp and within a week he had announced
his retirement and all the talk in that
off season was oh you're tarnishing your
legacy let me ask you this question the
day that Jerry Rice walked into Canton
do you think anybody remembered him
getting covered by a rookie free agent
from Bowling Green in kind of an
embarrassing situation no and no one
will remember Brady in an embarrassing
situation either no matter what happens
this year
yeah it feels like it's a foregone
conclusion he's going to play but I
brought this up on the Friday before
he's got to want him yeah well that's
why I said nobody was covering the story
of could this be Tom's last game if they
would lose to the Cowboys this might be
his last game everybody was already
moving ahead towards well he's going to
play somewhere next year and I thought I
wouldn't be so sure of that because at
some point Tom's got to be honest with
what his role was this year and he might
go you know what
this might be who I am right now and and
I don't know if he could have that
honesty and say I don't want to go out
there and play this kind of football
I don't want to play another year if I'm
going to play like this well that's why
in my opinion it has to be it's
essential that he goes somewhere that
has a good offensive line
you know because obviously he's going to
be immobile because he always has been
and you don't actually gain Mobility
from age 45 to 46. so he's got to have a
really good offensive line and I'm sure
he would be studying that wherever he
would go but I just think honestly I
think we got to give him a month and we
just got to let him veg out for a little
while and see what happens before I let
you go I'm trying to understand the
coaching search for the Denver Broncos
if the report is that Russell Wilson
wants Sean Payton and Sean I think is
accurate okay so
uh but is Sean Payton the leading
candidate here for the Denver is it his
job if he wants it I don't I don't know
the answer to that Dan I I don't cover
it the way I did 15 years ago but I do I
do know that what you just said is
absolutely true Russell Wilson does want
Sean Payton what happens now I mean look
here's what's been happening Dan he you
know he the coaching interviews have
been done by you know the owner's
representative as everybody knows uh
Greg Penner it's been done by George
Payton and sitting in on these
interviews and jetting all around for
all these interviews with them is
Condoleezza Rice
so this is not is a little bit different
from your pro forma coaching interview
and uh and I've heard from a couple of
people the condo Condoleezza Rice has
been great uh and she really is a huge
football fan and uh I just don't know
what any of that means but I do know
that if you have an investment in
Russell Wilson that probably for the
next couple of years either you can't or
you're unwilling to get out of uh I
think your smartest BET right now would
be to try to make a deal with Sean
Payton and obviously the Walton money is
going to be enough because look as of
now there's I believe five coaches in
the NFL
who make an average of 15 million or
more so you figure that if you're going
after Sean Payton it's probably 18 to 20
million a year and that's not going to
be anything I think it would be a big
problem for the uh for the Broncos is
David Shaw in the mix here
I don't know the answer to that I know
he talked and I mean David Shaw is
fantastic and David Shaw should be in
the mix in a lot of places just like
louanna rumo should be in a mix in a lot
of places the louisianarumo thing is
almost
is I don't know what to call it it's not
scandalous it's idiotic is what it is
how in the world can a guy who in the
last two post Seasons his defense has
allowed 19 points a game against some of
the great quarterbacks in this game and
how he doesn't get one interview it's
absolutely absurd
Peach safe travels as always we
appreciate your time okay Dan all the
best to you that's Peter King football
morning in America columnist and uh he's
going to Arrowhead to watch the Bengals
and the Chiefs